[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
i
anima
m
[Musique]
b
hop là
bp met
[Musique]
et
bonjour monsieur le président j'ai noté
comme tous mes confrères que le ton
avait changé entre le premier et le
second tour de cette campagne
présidentielle le ton s'est durci on
vous traite de menteur notamment oui
c'est vrai que le taux monte exagérément
ce n'est pas parce qu'on arrive à quatre
jours du deuxième tour du scrutin le
tour décisif qu'il faut pour cela perdre
la tête
et si l'on continue de surenchère en
surenchère ce soit très fâcheuses pour
l'esprit public voit la démocratie je ne
compte pas entrer dans cette mêlée
j'accepte de discuter bien entendu je
comprends très bien que parfois il y ait
de la vivacité mais il ne faut pas en
faire un système comme monsieur chirac
vous attaque qu'il évoque notamment la
sphère gordji alors est ce que vous êtes
indignés de ces attaques non je vais
simplement vous poser une question à
vous pouvez me répondre mais cela pose
au fond à tous ceux qui nous entendent
une affaire qui a provoqué pendant près
de cinq mois le siège le blocus de
l'ambassade d'iran en plein paris qui a
provoqué par contrecoup le siège de
l'ambassade de france à téhéran avec un
certain péril pour les français qui se
trouvaient là enfermé une affaire qui a
abouti à la rupture des relations
diplomatiques entre les deux pays
l'iran et la france est ce que vraiment
vous pouvez croire que tout cela a
reposé sur un dossier vide
il suffit de poser la question pour
comprendre la réponse
en outre la firme gordji et un nouvelle
calédonie qui reste un un point
difficile d'autant plus difficile qu'il
ya des otages des gendarmes pris en
otage sur l'île d'ouvéa est ce que vous
voyez quelques solutions proches
en tout cas la première préoccupation
majeure c'est que soient libérés
les gendarmes et le magistrat les 23
personnes qui se trouvent aujourd'hui
otage dans l'île d'ouvéa face et le
premier devoir du tour ouvert
de quelle façon cela naturellement
étudiés je pense que la médiation qui
avait été confiée à l'archevêque de
nouméa était de bonne méthode
elle échoué mais cette méthode peut être
mise au point qu'elle sorte que les
fonds ne soient plus rompus entre les
communautés en présence qui vivent
actuellement dans un climat de guerre
civile
or quel est le rôle de la république et
du président de la république c'est
d'exercer une sorte d'arbitrage de
tenter d'apaiser des passions ces deux
communautés les principales qui
s'affrontent celle qui est d'origine
européenne celle qui sur ce terrain de
la nouvelle calédonie a derrière el
cheikh et les milanais il faut qu'ils
puissent vivre ensemble sur la même
terre il ne s'agit pas de choisir celle
ci a raison contre celle là il s'agit de
permettre à l'une et à l'autre de vivre
là-bas correctement honorablement dans
la dignité et dans les droits que la
république reconnaît à tous ses citoyens
si on parvient à obtenir que soit libéré
les otages si l'on parvient et cette
fois je compte m'appliquer à rétablir
les ponts ténu qui subsistent encore
alors le droit arbitral le pouvoir à
pitre al de la république sera exercée
et dans les jours qui viennent
aujourd'hui même demain ne faut pas
perdre une heure tous nos efforts
doivent être associés au delà de nos
querelles internes pour obtenir ce
résultat
à l'issue du premier tour tous les
commentaires ont noté qu'il y avait eu
un vote de protestation très fort vote
de protestation qui travaillent sans
doute un un très grand mécontentement
alors est ce que on peut analyser
maintenant ce vote de mécontentement est
ce qu'il vient essentiellement de
difficultés de la vie quotidienne brézin
je pense que l'explication du pas
seulement politique supavud une
idéologie qui soudain flambé pour
apporter avec elle près de 15 % du corps
électoral je ne pense pas que cela soit
strictement politique ni idéologique
cela s'est produit sur un terrain qui
est lui même était il faut le dire
gangrené ce sont les difficultés
sociales les difficultés de la vie
quotidienne qui ont alimenté qui
alimente aurons encore demain si on n'y
prend garde tous les mouvements
excessifs à monsieur p r j'aimerais
qu'on précise ce qui selon vous a
suscité ce mécontentement dans la vie
quotidienne vous êtes libéré jeudi le
chômage
si on dit le chômage c'est-à-dire une
manque de formation des jeunes qui
sortent des écoles
et oui et vit surtout est trop trop de
chômeurs en fin de droits qui n'ont de
vente eux que le désespoir et
d'exclusion il est une possible que ces
femmes que ces hommes éprouvent un
sentiment de révolte contre la société
que nous dirigeons et le devoir de ceux
qui assument les responsabilités
principales dans cette société c'est de
s'attaquer désormais avec plus de
vigueur encore aux causes de ce mal il
ya le logement le logement qui n'est pas
toujours une correspondant à ce qu'on
attende ceux qui ont une famille il y à
la laideur souvent de certains quartiers
ou de la ville il y à la difficulté des
transports les difficultés scolaires la
liste serait longue
les difficultés de voisinage tant que
nous n'aurons pas comment c'est
d'organiser mieux aux grands centres
urbains
le même phénomène continuera de se
produire et j'observe à cet égard
que si l'on regarde bien la carte
politique telle qu'elle se dessine au au
lendemain du premier tour de scrutin
là vous le parti dont vous me parlez a
fait le moins de progrès et pourtant
dans des centres urbains où il ya
beaucoup de monde à forte densité et
bien c'est dans des quartiers où les
municipalités quelle que soit leur
couleur politique
ce sont vraiment attaquer à cette sorte
de lettre des quartiers pauvres
abandonné jointe à ces france par
exemple à hérouville-saint-clair
calvados je pense à orly pense à alençon
je pense à oullins dans le rhône vous
avez là une série de municipalités qui
n'ont pas voulu se laisser aller qui ont
voulu restituer à leurs populations
une certaine beauté ce président ça veut
dire que comme le rappelait relais mené
tirs au cours d'une heure de vérité
en fait il faut s'attaquer à des
problèmes très concrets que c'est le
rôle des hommes politiques s'attaquent
aux cages d'escaliers aux problèmes de
bruit et bien et même les siens avaient
dit en effet si l'on mettait en marche
remettait en marche les ascenseurs dans
les hlm ça irait mieux
cent fois raison et il y a quand même un
minimum de vie collective de vie sociale
qu'il faut savoir respecter des gens qui
vivent des familles par exemple ou et
couper la relation entre les différentes
générations
les petits enfants ne connaissent plus
des grands-parents dire comment pourrais
vivre les grands parents avec le reste
de la famille dans des logements trop
étroit chaque chose qui manque
les difficultés de la garde des enfants
leboeuf l'air une femme qui est envahie
que ces enfants ne sont pas de crèche ou
si âpre en tout cas des organisations
parentale et ainsi de suite
tous ceux qui marquent la difficulté de
la vie s'il faut mettre une heure et
demie pour le moins allez une heure et
demie pour le moins retour pour aller de
sa maison au lieu de son travail
j'imaginais l'épuisement l'épuisement
nerveux l'irritation qui gagne voilà on
rejette haut débit à cette société de
décidément elle ne me convient pas et ne
m'apporte pas le ce dont j'ai besoin le
minimum dont j'ai besoin
elle me laisse sur la touche elle mêle
sur la touche et on vote pour des
extrêmes alors les objectifs que vous
vous fixez pour essayer de pallier ces
difficultés sont mon premier objectif
c'est on a beaucoup parlé des grands
projets des grands travaux qui ont toqué
pays faut le dire ont ce que tu n as qui
s'achève maintenant je pense que les
grands travaux du prochain septennat
si les français veulent ce sera de
s'attaquer à ces problèmes de la vie
quotidienne et de commencer à les
résoudre
je pense que ceux qui auront la charge
la tête des ministères dans le futur
gouvernement de tous les secteurs qui
touchent aux problèmes que vivent du
matin au soir et du soir au matin
des millions et des millions de gens se
seront avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale les plus importants
l'expérience qu'il faut mettre en gage
et on a trop longtemps vécu trop loin de
ses brevets et pourquoi parce que les
hommes politiques se contentait du débat
politique à paris et descendez -
justement dans les quartiers non ce ne
serait pas tout à fait juste de donner
cette explication gars beaucoup d'hommes
politiques ont une grande expérience de
la vie locale dans ce qu'ils sont aussi
mis 6 po maires conseillers généraux
conseillers régionaux vraiment ils les
traitent bien mais à la hauteur de
l'état quelques grands problèmes
naturellement retiennent l'attention de
ceux qui gouvernent mais peut-être les
majorités ont-elles pas eu le moyen ou
long tail pas existe assez songez que la
première nécessité c'est de répondre au
malaise à l'anxiété à l'inconfort louis
à un beau jardin côté de la maison
et oui un espoir tout à côté la
possibilité de s'asseoir sur un banc de
places qui tourne en trouver je ne rêve
pas de la société pastorale
mais retrouver une vie convivial où on
aime discuter ensemble retrouver
peut-être les gens qui ont le même
accent que vous tout cela est
indispensable
les hommes se connaissent plus
dans la ville pourquoi je dis il faut
civiliser la ville mais ce président on
va vous dire à nouveau vous êtes
romantique et perceuses section de
civilisation plus solidaire c'est pas
pour tout de suite comme free bull que
moi a commenté ce extraordinaire du bio
cela je ne m'incite pas ceux qui
m'écoutent à rêver je les invite à
travailler mais que quand je quand je
vais j'y vais souvent dans céret loup ne
fait pas bon vivre
je me je pense même que les françaises
et les français ont une grande patience
d'une certaine manière je vous dirais je
comprends qu'ils se révoltent et dans
mes fonctions de président de la
république
j'en souffre j'ai envie vraiment de
créer un élan de mobiliser les énergies
pour qu'on se prononcent attaque
désormais par priorité je répète encore
avec celui de l'éducation nationale et
de la formation des jeunes aux problèmes
de la vie quotidienne avec patience sans
romantisme avec méthode et avec réalisme
voilà par quoi il faut commencer
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
coupez
aux places
[Musique]